j'aimerais vous faire partager quelque
chose que je fais tout seul intimement
puisque là effectivement il ya il ya
beaucoup d'émotion et je suis très
heureux d'être ici avec vous et
j'aimerais pouvoir me connecter avec ce
que je suis réellement et donc avec le
coeur puisque l'enjeu c'est le coeur on
le sait tous trente secondes en mettant
mon attention à l'intérieur pour pouvoir
me connecter à moi et vous parlez avec
le coeur pourquoi porter un autre regard
sur soi et sur le monde
j'ai compris que si je voulais changer
le monde
il fallait tout d'abord je commence par
mois comment j'y suis parvenu je vais
vous parler de mon chemin de vie ce que
ça m'a apporté les esprits doué pour
l'abstrait ou les disciplines cognitive
se sent tout à fait à l'aise dans la
structure d'enseignement pratiqués en
france et vous
pourquoi et comment avez vous vécu votre
scolarité
personnellement je n'ai pas compris le
sens cette façon de transmettre le
savoir et l'adéquation entre cet acquis
est le sens de la vie à l'époque je ne
savais pas mais il me fallait des choses
plus concrètes physique relié avec tous
les jours passionné par le sport
je m'engage donc dans la voix de sport
études
c'est de cette façon que j'ai pratiqué
pendant cette année le foot
puis le judo ce fut d entraînement
rigoureux et engagé jusqu'au jour où à
cause d'une mauvaise formation de mon
dos je dois arrêter le sport
ce fut un choc
comme si tout l'univers s'écrouler
autour de moi tout était remis en cause
comme si tout d'un coup la lumière
s'éteignait
je vis cette interdiction comme une
injustice et mon caractère que je sais
anticonformiste devient alors révolté
rebelles
le corps enseignant choisi pour moi la
filière du bâtiment
je refuse je ne suis pas d'accord
et comme par instinct je choisis la
ville la filière bois est large découvre
ce matériau vivant sensible avec des
couleurs des odeurs des textures je suis
en harmonie avec ce matériau je sens un
lien
je me sens bien cependant je ne suis pas
d'accord on fait tout à fait d'accord
avec la transformation de ce matériau je
produis des cadres des fenêtres
donc je ne suis pas d'accord sur un plan
utilitaires je m'interroge sur le sens
le symbole l'expression du ressenti
toutes ces choses qui sont complexes à
définir avec des mots
je quitte la formation conventionnelles
pour me diriger à nouveau vers une
formation de sculptures dans cette
formation deux événements vont
transformer ma vie
le premier c'est ma rencontre avec jean
noël un sculpteur ébéniste un
intervenant extérieur par son regard sur
le monde
il va m'en richir par son ouverture
d'esprit
il va m'en richir par sa bienveillance
envers l'environnement il vraiment rien
et surtout il va me donner confiance en
moi puis il y à cette anecdote lorsque
je suis amené à sculpter un masque
africain baoulé du nom de la tribu situe
en côte d'ivoire c'est de cette façon
diffuse et intuitive que je comprends
que derrière ce simple objet il y a un
véritable sens
une émotion un souvenir un langage
permettant de transmettre des
informations autrement que par des
concepts manteau en sculptant ce masque
non seulement je me révèle mais je me
dévoile mon parcours initiatique des
buts
quelques années après je décide de
partir en afrique australe
car je suis en quête de sens je ressens
le besoin d'aller à l'intérieur et ce
d'une manière profonde d'aller à la
source
je ressens le besoin d'aller au coeur
des forêts vierges et des tribus c'est
ce que je fais là bas ma vie change mon
regard se confronte à une autre culture
une autre façon de concevoir le monde
je fais face je me libère à ce que je
suis réellement j'ai envie d'être ce que
je suis réellement et non pas ce que la
société où les hôtes pour m imposer
d'être je comprends comment le regard
des autres peut nous empêcher d'être soi
je veux être acteur de mon histoire je
décide de faire ma révolution culturelle
et c'est au coeur de l'afrique par
l'intermédiaire de la lecture que je
découvre la poésie la philosophie la
psychologie qui vont beaucoup m'inspire
et surtout le psychologue carl gustav
jung
en effet à travers ses nombreux voyages
et ses réflexions il créé un concept clé
la liberté des contraires ou ce qu'ils
nomment encore le principe
d'individuation ce concept qui fait
débat auquel j'adhère complètement
repose sur le processus de création la
distinction d'un individu il se rapporte
à la réalisation du soin qui prend en
compte les éléments progressivement
conflictuelles et contradictoires qui
forment la totalité psychique
conscientes et inconscientes de
cet individu ce concept pour moi résonne
énormément comme une énergie à
l'intérieur qui s'éveille
je sens que le changement est vital je
sens je comprends que le changement se
passe par l'intérieur on processus
d'intériorisation continue après cinq
années en afrique
je décide de rentrer en france afin de
faire une formation forestière pour à
nouveau repartir avec cette expertise
mais le passé me rattrape suite à un
bilan médical
je suis à nouveau refusé pour les même
raisons qui m'ont obligé à arrêter le
sport je suis à nouveau confrontés à un
refus à une injustice de ne pas pouvoir
faire ce que j'ai envie de faire
résigné j'ai horreur de ce mot mais
optimiste je décide de rester en france
et de repartir en afrique un peu plus
tard et à cette période je fais deux
rencontres déterminantes
une occasion à moi ce présent d'investir
un bâtiment je saisis cette opportunité
je décide donc de rester en france
en ouvrant une activité là je commence à
travailler avec des objets des oeuvres
et je m'interroge je ressens un lien
entre certains de ces objets certaines
de ses oeuvres et ma recherche
intérieure vers un autre regard je sens
que c'est là et pour répondre à mes
interrogations
j'actualise mon savoir
en réalisant une formation en histoire
de l'art en parallèle de mon activité et
enfin je découvre et qu'on prend enfin
le langage de ces objets c'est ce qui va
me donner le désir tout d'abord de
présenter ses oeuvres différentes puis
de produire ses oeuvres afin d'éduquer
afin d'initier l'éveil d'un autre regard
j'ai besoin de moyens et la vie me
laporte sous différentes formes
voici un de ces objets comment
trouvez-vous cet objet quel regard lui
porte et vous quelle est son utilité
comme vous le voyez c'est exactement la
proportion représentative d'un témoin de
relais de course il est en ébène il est
doré à la feuille d'or en son coeur se
cache une cavité où on peut mettre des
éléments intimes à conserver ou à
transmettre c'est un objet
symboliquement fort il a quitté le
terrain des enjeux sportifs pour se ré
introduire seulement dans la
transmission
il a effacé son esprit de conquête pour
se placer sur une dimension unique de
partage c'est un objet qui devient
particulier on lui attribue les vertus
un pouvoir comme un porte-bonheur
une amulette c'est un objet apotropaïque
pour produire ces objets ceci est un
exemple je choisis des plasticiens des
designers des architectes des graphistes
ainsi que des savoir-faire tourneur sur
bois brodeuses d'horreur en leur
demandant de produire des objets avec
deux idées principales
que ces objets contemporains puisse
intégrer une symbolique au même titre
qu'un eu un objet tribal ou religieux il
s'agit de questionner une possible
valeur d' usage en relation ou en
conflit avec la forme tout en gardant
une référence personnelle une amulette
ou collective un totem la divine
proportion appelée encore le nombre d'or
où le code secret cette formule
mathématique datant de l'antiquité qui
régit les arts elle détermine la
proportion d'une forme
on la retrouve dans l'adn humain le
développement des plantes
le système solaire elles représentent
l'harmonie l'équilibré entre les hommes
et la nature
c'est ce qui m'intéresse c'est ce
pourquoi je produis des oeuvres l'art
doit nous élever l'art doit produire du
symbole l'art doit participer au
changement nous faire prendre conscience
d'un autre regard afin d'unir les hommes
et la nature
william blake qui a réalisé la première
oeuvre et celles ci nous dit le monde de
l'imaginaire et le monde de l'éternité
je suis le rapport que j'établis avec ce
que je vois et je change quand ce que je
vois prend une autre phase ces objets
ont transformé mon regard sur moi même
j'ai compris que d'être différent c'est
d'être soit sincère authentique l'échec
fait partie de la réussite
je remercie la vie
cette transformation a modifié mon
regard sur le monde
je crois en une réalité en dehors de
l'espace et du temps
je crois en une énergie omniprésente
c'est ce que représente pour moi cet
objet c'est ce que matérialise pour moi
cet objet la réalisation du soin comme
l'aboutissement de l'évolution ce n'est
pas une finalité
c'est un passage vers un autre regard
sur soi et sur le monde
merci